I remember watching uh the this this
Vlog that you put out where you asked
chat gbt to uh curate the dialogue do
you know that like a bunch yeah so what
the video was is I wrote to chat or gbt4
the latest which you have to pay like
nine dollars a month yeah get your
credits out dude
nine dollars a month for God
I know how dare they and I the product
was like writing Casey neistat Vlog and
then I just made that Vlog exactly as it
said to make it yeah and it was like
funny it was meant to be funny and silly
because it was so basic when it's like
the script was it's really silly but
like the AI folks like the real hardcore
AI people on Twitter were like super
[__] angry at me why why because
they're like had you worked harder had
you trained that AI yeah had you put
real effort into this you could have
really shown what its true potential is
and it could have better mimicked your
creativity and I was like
that's not the [__] point
no one knows what the [__] you're
talking about Everyone's an idiot like
me I don't know how to use this thing
it's brand new right it's been out for
like a month like you give it a basic
prompt then what it gives you back like
that was the interestingness for me yeah
was not how good you could make it but
was like at first glance like remember
Google like 2001 where it just like it
was amazing yeah and this was kind of
amazing it was meant to be playful there
are two things in it that I thought were
brilliant one was uh you saying
afterwards the importance of Soul yeah
and like heart in content and that's the
thing that we connect to and the fact is
that AI it it can't even really mimic
that yet and you were like maybe if I
gave it more prompts it could mimic like
heart and soul and like passion and but
that's kind of what separates a great
piece of work
but the other thing that I liked is it
looked at every single one of your Vlogs
right and one of the things that I've
always loved about your content is
there's not bitterness in it
you're not [__] bitter when you're
angry about something you make fun of it
yeah when you're angry about the bike
ticket you don't go [__] the police this
is why this City's falling apart and
which is like the easiest lowest form of
content is just to be like this sucks
everybody sucks I know how the world
works you all suck everybody's work to
me instead you just prove how absurd it
is to give somebody a bike ticket when
they're not in the bike lane that might
be your most impressive Vlog because the
amount of times you fell off the bike
how old were you then
I was not a young man
from anything right now I'm like I might
not ever get up
you're just throwing yourself off a
bicycle I knew when we were shooting
that it was like how committed the Falls
were was gonna sell that video no helmet
was crazy also